make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing with the
Thanos imperative of the story like the
most epic Thanos story ever okay so
continuing with this battle on the
frontlines like this is when stuff
starts to get bananas right it gets it
gets straight up bananas here's think
people who have read this story are just
like dude issue number two is when it
gets crazy I guess absolutely crazy I
really hope you guys are doing this but
of course you you initially pick out
with Richard Ryder right now here's see
here's a thing this is why people who
were fans of Richard where there were
there were only over two generations of
fans when it came to Richard Ryder
people who were fans of him originally
when his stories first came out which
are old fans were people who picked up
with a cosmic landscape from Dan Abnett
and annihilation who became fans at that
point and who some people loved Richard
writers so much right because this guy
goes in when it comes to like facing off
against these various foes and different
things like that
and for the most part he's able to hold
his own but like the front line is
falling rapidly right like this it's
literally crashing down around them
these many angled ones are just too
difficult to kill if there was like any
other normal circumstance this this
fight would have been over pretty
quickly or at the very least these guys
would be able to hold their own and it
wouldn't really be a stalemate so much
as them pushing back the tide but like
these many angled ones are just too
difficult to kill because they're just
so powerful and so where some of these
guys get obliterated suddenly the Silver
Surfer comes out of nowhere right I like
comes out of nowhere punch is open the
mouth of one of these things and then
like when he's asked by Nova like are
you on our slide the silver surfers like
no I'm just a hero forces have been
assembled and that's when you get like
Galactus you get ages u get tenebrous
and you get all of the Celestials okay
so a little bit of history here for
those of you guys who were unfamiliar
with with aegis and tenebrous because
you're probably like who in the heck of
even are these characters they're hugely
powerful right they're wildly powerful
they were powerful enough to go
toe-to-toe with the Silver Surfer and
even fight Galactus to a bit but the
idea was that at the beginning of all
things and this is something to kind of
keep in mind but we've talked about the
ordens of the universe and the
beginnings of life and different things
like that and there's different versions
of it right the Asgardians have their
own origin of the universe al Ewing and
The Ultimates form his own origin of the
universe and different things like that
but at the time that this story came out
this was one of many origins right so
you can kind of take it or leave it and
but at one point there was a guy there
was a being called idea Blair II I think
is what his name was and he was one of
what were called the promeo gods and
aegis and tenebrous stood alongside him
along with a host of others and the idea
was that these beings were mostly prime
is really what they were in so far that
their job was to basically set the
universe in motion to where life would
start to form in different things like
that now again we've talked about it of
different origins how like the
Celestials were the ones that did that
and so on and so forth again this is one
of the many origins that are out there
but the the idea was once their role as
a prime mover was fulfilled and
essentially the ball was rolling and the
earth I'm sorry the the universe was off
to creating its own life by virtue of
like planets crashing into each other
and different things like that and you
know world heating up and single-celled
organisms becoming multi-celled
organisms and so on ultimately there was
no need for them anymore
and so what ended up happening is that
diya Blair II alongside are really kind
of corrupted Aegis and tenebrous but
kind of brought them on board to his
cause and essentially instigated a civil
war among the promeo gods this war
eventually came to the doorstep of
Galactus who single-handedly obliterated
pretty much all of them except for ages
and tenebrous who were locked away in
the kiln which is basically this kind of
galactic prison that sits on the very
edge of space for the crunchiest which
is kind of like the the ends of the
universe and so as a result of that they
sat there sort of kept in this prison
for a long long time now all this came
to a head during the story of
annihilation and that's when he started
getting characters like The Fallen who
was like the first Herald of Galactus
who ultimately was imprisoned in the
kiln as well when the annihilation wave
swept through the universe and basically
started like destroying everything he
came across it also led to this kind of
massive prison break at the kiln which
of course saw the Fallen one escape
which led to the whole conflict between
him and Thanos as well as ages and
tenebrous escaping as well now
ultimately they ended up getting until I
kind of a conflict with Galactus of
sorts they fought the Silver Surfer and
then in turn fought Galactus and things
kind of popped off from there but the
power these beings possess is immense
right like ages basically channel's the
the power of the crunch right the power
of the universe's formation more or less
as ambiguous as that is and then
tenebrous channels what's called like
black energy basically the kind of
matter that holds universes together
these are basically long and short end
and really ambiguous and and non clear
ways of saying they're cosmic beings
like their cosmic leaf powered beings
the fact that they're here alongside
Galactus and all the Celestials means
that this is a huge event right this is
a massive thing right we don't really
even seen anything like this during
anihilation right so it shows just how
huge this conflict is in comparison to
annihilation and we'll talk more about
that here in a second what we end up
doing is jumping over to the cancerverse
itself and picking up with the guardians
of the galaxy alongside Thanos
Thanos is essentially unconscious during
this entire conflict but when you have
the guardians of the galaxy facing off
against all these various people it's
cool to see the Dan Abbot doesn't just
throw it away right like one of the
things he says is he has like you know
what this version of dr. strange being
so powerful he has moondragon user
powers to cut the the telepathic
abilities I've never even telepathic but
to kind of keep the mind to these guys
close so that if anybody out there is
listening to what's going on kind of
keeping track by it by maintaining a
link with their mental minds did that
link will basically break off and so as
a result of that mantas steps in she
shuts down dr. strange and the conflict
basically unfolds from there and it's a
cool thing to see because he's
characters for the most part go toe to
toe albeit they're all defeated by the
guardians of the galaxy and so when that
happens the Guardians essentially kill
them all but remember they're in a
cancerverse they're in an in a universe
where nothing can ever die and so what
is up happening is that with these
various forces once they're all
quote/unquote believed to have been dead
they basically mutate and then rise yet
again and that's kind of how things
continually go right every time you kill
something and mutates and then it comes
back so that's when Thanos starts to
wake out and it's a cool thing because
these guys are basically like I don't
know who this guy is but he scares the
crap outta me it's one of the coolest
things because Stannis basically uses
all of his power and just blasts these
guys into oblivion and what this does is
it basically says stano's as the living
avatar of death can bring death to the
cancerverse
and that's why it is that Marvel and his
forces are trying to capture the avatar
of death because as the avatar of death
he basically is death in human form
right so he's like if mistress death
became a person and decided to walk
around he channels for power to bring
death to everything and so what that
means is that if you were to go
toe-to-toe against Lord Marvell and win
then he would ultimately end up killing
Lord Marvell as well as anybody else to
the cancer burst that's why they're
afraid of him that's why they want to
remove him from the board but it's also
why he's important and we'll talk about
why danos is the single most important
character do have the entirety of this
story because in the middle of all this
one ends up happening is they're
suddenly met by the arrival of the
vision who simply says I'm not here to
bring you any harm what it does after
that is it jumps back to the major
conflict on the wall right to the front
line of the fault and like all these
forces that are pouring through and this
is one of these single coolest parts of
the story Institute is amazing how cool
this is right because I mean I mean look
at this landscape of forces here right
like you've got all these major empires
who are doing the best they can just to
live right it's kind of the some of
is between this and annihilation in
annihilation all this crazy the story
picked up with like basically refugee
groups just like fleeing for their lives
and just trying to stay alive that's
what's happening here
right like they're doing the best they
can but it's just an it's an absolute
massacre about anything I've ever
watched Star Trek
if you guys remember Star Trek first
contact with like the board we're
heading towards Earth and just
annihilating the Federation ships and
they were just sending out SOS is all
over the place and it's like anybody who
can help us just please like anyone it
doesn't even matter who you are just
help us like that's literally what this
is just like somebody somewhere help us
and so you have all these various forces
coming in but it's kind of a funny thing
because one of the things is commented
on by by Nova as what was window Vaughn
is that like the fact that these
entities are here the fact that cosmic
entities have stepped in really shows
the significance of this event that's
going on here and what this means is a
solar surfer kind of chimes in and he
says it's not just this universe the
reason why the cosmic entities are here
is because it's not just this universe
that's at stake it's all the universes
that are at stake as well now here's the
important thing to understand and this
is the question people are going to ask
where is the Living Tribunal in all of
this right because you would think if
one universe managed to invade another
universe that ultimately the Living
Tribunal would step in and say there's a
magical imbalance here no that's not the
way it works because remember the living
tribunals job is not to keep universes
separate it's not to keep universes from
crossing over with each other the living
tribunals job is to maintain magical
balance right to maintain magical energy
there and so in this circumstance the
mistress death because of the way that
she was killed and because of why she
died in in the cancerverse universe
which we'll talk about uh what this
basically means is that like the natural
order of things was more or less
maintained that where the Silver Surfer
says their actions are unnatural it's
not true at least it's not not the case
and as it pertains to the Living
Tribunal but the reality is if the
universe can't maintain itself against
an external force then the universe will
succumb to whatever that external force
happens to be it's the natural order of
things the weak make way for the strong
is how things have always worked it's
the the the rule of logic letting
Tribunal applied when it came to Thanos
using the Infinity stones and then
wanting to take over the role of
eternity right during the original
Infinity Gauntlet story if eternity was
empower phul enough to maintain its role
then Thanos would replace it and that's
basically what's going on here albeit
from one universe to another as opposed
from one galaxy to another or one planet
to another within
universe itself and so that's why things
are so huge is because in the midst of
all this what you suddenly have is this
kind of coalescing like this kind of
coming out with regards to some entity
or some force passing through the rift
itself and when everybody starts to look
up and everybody starts to panic
everybody starts to freak wondering what
this is Mina finding out they have every
reason to freak out because what's
coming out of this giant rift is the
Galactus engine with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end cliffhangers if you are new here to
comment explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the bob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop and I will catch you all
later peace
[Laughter]
[Music]